Another thing you can look at
is the Sales Performance Report.
You go to Conversions,
e-commerce, Sales Performance.
In this report,
groups results by transaction.
You can drill down into a transaction
to see what the products
included in the transaction.
Here I've only got one
product per transaction,
because our app assumes that the current
dinner is the only product in the cart.
But here's an example from a different
app with more transactions, so
drill down into this transaction ID.
And you see that the customer
bought several things in a single
purchase transaction.
And the revenue for the transaction
is the sum of the prices for
the products included
in the transaction.
In this transaction, the customer
bought several different shirts.
So the total revenue is the sum
of the cost of all of the shirts.
That's a lot of shirts for one person.
I hope they all fit.
So far in our app,
when the user hits the purchase button,
they buy the currently selected dinner.
And they pretty much have
no choice about that.
But usually customers like to
buy things by the cartload,
rather than selecting and
paying for items one by one.
So to tell analytics that
the user bought multiple products
in a single transaction,
you just add whatever products you need
to the hit to be sent to analytics.
Create a product object for
each product in the cart, set the name,
set all the other details and so on.
Then you create the product action,
you set the action to ACTION_PURCHASE.
Set the TransactionId and then you can
optionally set a ProductActionList,
if you want to group all
the products into a list.
You don't have to do that though.
And then you get the tracker, as before.
And you add each of
the products to the tracker and
then you build and send the hit.
And this is pretty much the code that
you've already learned how to write.
The only difference, really,
is that you can add multiple products.
Now I know some people say it's not
polite to talk about money in public,
but I really do want to bring up
a couple of matters to do with money.
Every product has its own price.
This shirt costs 10.
And when you send an action
purchase hit to analytics,
the total price of the transaction
is automatically calculated
from the price and the quantity of
the products in the transaction.
That's cool, right?
Kind of what you'd expect, sure is.
But if you take a look at the API
reference for product action,
you'll see there are methods for setting
the revenue, the tax and the shipping.
If the tax and
the shipping are relevant,
you'll need to write the code
to add them to the transaction.
Remember I said that you can
set the name of the list
that's associated with
a given set of products?
If applicable, by setting the
ProductActionList on the ProductAction.
The list name shows up on
the product list performance page.
And in this case there
is two product lists,
one without a name, and
the other one is all the things.
And then if you drill
down into all the things,
you see the products that
were in the product list, and
you can find out what they contributed
to the product revenue for the list.
I don't have a coding exercise for
you related to calculating taxes or
setting product lists, but
feel free to explore on your own.
Up next though, you do have a quiz.